our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us the
Little League Baseball World Series
starts next week but one team is already
making history the Mamie Johnson Little
League team is the first predominantly
african-american team from Washington DC
to advance to the regional tournament
and it is just a few years old DeMarco
Morgan met the team at the regionals in
Bristol Connecticut when everyone raced
onto the field to celebrate maybe
Johnston's win in the DC Little League
championship last month the team knew
they had done something special what's
it like making history amazing history
is like a once-in-a-lifetime thing
Rocco Gilbert Dajuan Taylor Daniel
Marshall and their teammates came from
behind to defeat the Capitol Hill lead
they became the first majority black
youth team to win the district
tournament setting them on a path
towards the Little League World Series
[Music]
their win was so meaningful that when it
came time to raise money for the 330
mile journey to regionals in Connecticut
the very opponents they beat were among
those who donated funds what does that
mean to you to see so many people coming
out and just cheering you guys on and
they care about us just four years ago
the baby Johnson Little League didn't
exist and some of its members had never
even played baseball were you guys
interested in playing baseball before
the league or on No
I ain't going in 2015 the league teamed
up with the Washington Nationals a youth
baseball academy the mission at the
youth baseball academy is to use
baseball and softball as vehicles to
foster positive character development
academic enrichment and improved health
I mean it's not just the 13 boys on this
team it's the whole family here at the
Academy the Academy sits at Ward 7 one
of the poorest neighborhoods in
Washington DC you think that because we
live in southeast or in Ward 7 that we
normally play football basketball so it
was kind of good to show them that we
can play baseball too what's it like
living there what do you see like
carjacking stealing but none of that is
really affecting me and stopping me from
playing baseball I make sure I stay away
from the negativity stay with the
positive how does it make you feel to
know that you are that male figure that
sort of being positive for them and
pushing them in the right direction is
it tough it's tough but it's rewarding
Keith Barnes the founder and president
of the league says his mission extends
beyond baseball our goal was to change
the culture in that part of DC football
and basketball is key to see 300 kids
playing baseball and really loving it
and some of the challenges aren't like
they don't have gloves so we fundraise
we have sponsors and you never turn a
child away who was never no child one
day the Nationals Academy might funnel
kids from this community into
professional baseball less than 10
percent of major league baseball players
are African American and why do you
think this program is important for
young boys who look like you to be
involved it's important because we could
be leaders too
the younger kids to make them grow up
and like do the same thing we did and be
better they told me I not getting in
trouble so you're staying out of trouble
as a result yes what do you say to the
naysayers the folks who never thought
you would even make it this far I love
my eaters when somebody says something
negative towards me not only makes me
work harder expect I expect the
unexpected is right and while the team
won't make it to the Little League World
Series after losing their game on
Tuesday bummer right well they said they
still feel like winners and a
congresswoman I meanwhile invited them
to tour the Capitol and a DC
councilmembers introduced in a
ceremonial resolution and the team's
honor and guys I got to be honest with
you I can personally relate to what
they're going through and just to see
them power through yes our futures and
you're right there's two winners and we
love Rocco and his raspy voice hashtag
love my hair my hair words to live by
sounds like a Louis Armstrong a little
Louie yes shines beyond his years
they are few leaders DeMarco thank you
thank you